I will predict and guarantee really that
this is going to be a
greater than 100 million dollar a year
Revenue business which means it's going
to be worth something like
low end
300 400 million high-end billion dollars
[Music]
all right we are live sorry I missed
last week how to do a thing but
today's a big day for me I'm launching
my thing I'm finally talking about the
thing that I've been working on it's
called Hampton joinhampton.com
uh I'm I'm excited this is your Steve
Jobs moment dude is it every once in a
while something comes along
that changes everything
[Laughter]
triangle hand pose yeah I'm just gonna
start a city like that this is the first
time that I've been working on something
that I haven't talked about it like
within 24 hours of having the idea and
it's killed me
it's killed me and I have hated it I've
hated it I'm so nervous and so why now
so I'll give people background so my new
company that I've been working on I
think I've been working on it since July
but I've had the idea for a long time
and I like even interviewed people in
this space on the Pod
so by the way that's the funniest part
of this whole thing you invited people
out of the podcast ask them every hey uh
how do you run your business how do you
grow it what are the numbers how much
money does it make how'd you start it
Where'd you hire from blah blah blah and
then you just launched a competitor like
90 days later
it's not a competitor so we had a chief
on this is not a competitive Chief we
had tiger 21 on not a competitor there
to them but yeah so I wanted to prove
because I you remember how I said I hate
the question when people say how would
you start if you could do it over again
yada yada and I would tell them they go
well it's easy for you have an audience
and so I was like all right well I'll
just do it in front of you and just to
prove to myself and this little chip I
have on my shoulder that I can create
stuff without an audience so
Hampton is the URL is join Hampton I
couldn't get hampton.com uh it's like
owned by the Holiday Inn or whatever the
Marriott company or whatever it is
um
but it's it's pretty simple it's a
vetted Network for Founders and
entrepreneurs so basically if you're a
Founder our sweet spot is like if you're
the CEO of a company our sweet spot is
like 10 million a year in Revenue but
you need at least a million in Revenue
at least three million in funding or
well these are all over explain what it
does before yeah what's what I'm going
to so what I'm saying is you need like
it's for a certain size of CEO but
basically you sign up we vet you and
I'll an interview and all this stuff and
what you get is basically what you and I
had so before Sean and I started this
pod before he started this pod him and I
would meet once a month it would be me
you and like five or six other guys and
we would like it was basically like
group therapy for business and we did it
for a couple of years and then we did it
informally for a long time and I've done
it I've done it informally with a bunch
of people
but it kind of changed my life and so
we decided my partner Joe and I to
create that but for people who are all
over the country so if you're in Idaho
and you have this company that does like
20 million in Revenue you're kind of
like a freak you're like an outsider in
your community and so what we did was we
made this thing where you can sign up
get vetted and we put you in a group of
eight to ten people with a executive
coach we call them facilitators who
guide conversations that you have once a
month and then there's a hampton-wide
community that you um
can talk to other people anytime and
then we're we host dinners so we have
like dozens of dinners we have uh
Adventures so like a bunch of members
are going to a rally car event next week
and so we do all these things but
basically it's like I hate using this
but it's almost like a safe space so we
have people like posting you went there
I really care about this business I went
there it's like a place where you could
like talk to your would you say that
yours feel seen
you can bring your whole self
but you can bring your work self and
your personal self but it's like a place
where like let's say you have to lay
people off you can you can ask people
publicly and No One's Gonna Make fun of
you like I have to lay people off how do
I do this or you could be like I'm
bummed I'm really sad I have to lay
people off or the opposite you're like
I'm killing it money is coming in how
are you folks investing and so when I
had my group I used to do one with you
and I did one with my now partner Joe
Spicer like
he knew my net worth he knew my
relationship issues with friends and
family he knew when I was selling the
company I was like dude how do I not
look stupid when I'm selling this this
company I like I I I feel very ashamed
about X Y and Z and so it's this place
where you can it's kind of like this pod
but more intimate and uh
that's kind of why we had the idea I
didn't want to launch it publicly
because a I wanted the product to be
perfect like I wanted it to be great and
B communities like this it's not like
software where you just throw bodies at
it and it doesn't matter how many people
are using it we had to like really be
careful so we've added all these awesome
people and we like it was very hand
curated and it still will be but like I
wanted to be like that early on
and so
um
so I think you pitched it and you almost
didn't do yourself Justice there you
know when people come on the Pod and
you're like well let me just do that for
you real quick that's dude this is my
nerd man yeah yeah I feel like the
nerves are getting the best of you
because uh here's how I would explain
this I think you got the I think you got
one part right which was
most important the most important thing
which was you were a customer of a
product like this before you built this
business you didn't just build this
business because you're like oh this
might be a great idea uh when we met I
don't know 10 years ago almost
it was
through something like this we created a
group it was me it was you
Jack Smith who went on to sell his
business for like I don't know 700 800
900 million dollars uh but at the time
he he wasn't in that spot
um a guy named sieva who was at the time
doing this kind of class notes College
business that wasn't really gonna end up
being that big but his next thing uh
enduring Adventures has turned out to be
pretty big so it's a 100 million dollar
plus company now
um there was a small group of us and we
would meet twice a month and
there was one really important thing
that it did which was it gave you like
you said the safe space now what is it
safe from well
for most CEOs most of the time
um I would say most people think
starting a business is hard or being a
CEO is hard but they think about the
beginning like oh it must be hard to
like get the idea or get it off the
ground and like as anybody who's
actually done it knows that's like one
percent of the journey like the hard
part is actually the climb it's like
once you've got your idea and you're
running it yeah like now
seven years of day to day with a bunch
of unknowns and a bunch of like fires
that are going to pop out of nowhere and
you have to you have to put out those
fires and just staying happy and healthy
insane and being who you are during that
seven year climb is actually the hard
part and so who helps you during that
climb is I think the important part and
you know the hard thing if you're a CEO
is you talk to investors you got to tell
them everything's great everything is up
and up and up
um we're crushing it you talk to your
customers you need to tell them how
great everything is you talk to your
employees or your teammates in the
office every day you can't be telling
them about all your problems uh you have
to again tell them how great everything
is so this was for us this was the one
group or you could just say how things
actually are this is what's going good
this is what's going bad I don't even
really know about this other thing I
gotta figure that out I've been
procrastinating that just because it's
like looming and I don't I don't really
know what to do
and it is this founder group therapy
thing where you sit down with you know
six or seven other people and uh I would
say it's like 70 the conversation is
like 70 tactics thirty percent
dude I've been there you know don't
worry about this like the therapy but
the value is almost on the other side
it's like uh the connections that you
make
um you know the ideas that you get the
relationships like you know sieve ended
up uh you know being one of my groomsmen
I think in my wedding uh you know we
invested in a bunch of companies from
The Mastermind and that made a bunch of
money uh you know had I not been in a
mastermind with you I wouldn't have seen
how you built the hustle and I wouldn't
have known how to build the milk Road a
business I didn't know I was planning to
create five years later but that
blueprint was etched in my brain from
those meetings and so you get all these
like kind of crazy
um outsized benefits and basically I
think most people massively overrate the
idea of a mentor because I think it
sounds like the easy button it's like
man I wish that there was just some some
genius who knew everything and had done
everything who could just tell me what
to do and solve all my problems and of
course that doesn't really exist uh but
like so mentors are pretty overrated but
peers I think are massively underrated
and what you've done is basically curate
a bunch of
people who are like you so if you're in
that kind of like I've got a successful
business I'm on my seven year climb I
want to make this as big and as
generational as I can you want other
people who have already done that or
also in that Journey with you doing that
at the same time so that's my my sales
pitch for you you've done it better than
me uh you've absolutely thank you you've
done it way better than I did it's just
like
well well the other thing is I'm in the
thick of it too I'm not doing this
really for you I remember the first
piece of viral content I had was me
writing how I set my how I set up our
Mastermind how we ran it and how you
should like if you want to do that too
here's how you should do it and this was
like I had some crappy PDF somewhere
um but it's been downloaded like I don't
know 10 000 times now wow I don't even
know where those emails are I should go
find them but like that thing has had
like ten thousand ten thousand downloads
now in a couple years because and I
don't promote this thing it's just I
said it once on a podcast a long time
ago at the very beginning of this and
consistently people it resonates people
are like I want that how do I
how do I set mine up so I can have my
own version of what you have now what
you did you made it easy you made it a
product you were like don't worry about
figuring out how to find the right
people how to organize this how to make
sure the discussion is not a huge waste
of everyone's time and it's super
productive you just turned that into
push a button and if you're accepted in
you you get all that out of the box
which is smart
and I used your thing I I used that uh
the down or the list that you're talking
about I used
um just my experience with our thing and
then I went and studied it you know I
was talking to a lot of other of these
groups and trying to figure out I've
been calling it speed of vulnerability
how do we like get people to be
vulnerable quickly and it sounds weird
but we have like people like crying at
some of these things and I'm like yes
yes got him tears fuel me yeah
the tears of my customers
well particularly men like men are like
I'll have like some people afterwards
they're like this was amazing why
haven't other people done this I'm like
yeah dude it's called therapy like
people have done this for years and just
a lot of men in particular don't do this
type of stuff that's why I haven't
joined I don't want to cry last time I
cried somebody gave me a titty twister
and I just decided after that day it's
not happening again
um so yeah I've been avoiding your your
emotional trap here uh for a little bit
by the way this is not just something
you studied like oh there's these three
companies that started in the last 10
years that do this
um this is like on some Benjamin
Franklin right like this is a I
think uh junto or junto I don't know
what he called I don't know how you
pronounce it but like
back in the day this was like a Ben
Franklin thing even every Friday he
would go to this like one bar you might
know the story better than I do I'll
kind of butcher do it but he went to
this bar every Friday and he invited a
community of like-minded people and he
called it I think a society a a club of
mutual benefit like benefit or something
like that which is basically meant it's
a club of people who we are going to
make each other better
um like I want sparring partners when it
comes to business it's kind of the way
that that that you you think about it or
I think about it uh but he was doing the
same thing his was a little less A
Little Less business oriented it's a
little more like uh
topics of you know society and law and
whatever like they would just debate
random things
um but he like attributed a lot of his
success to doing this regularly to
having this regular recurring meeting
with peers who played the game at a high
level and that makes you know iron
sharpens iron type of thing and so um
yeah this is not like a new idea that's
been around for a little while how do
you think about how this Compares so
people have heard of oh YPO they've
heard of whatever these other ones tiger
21 vistage all all these things how does
it compare I know I I have my opinion
you might have to be politically correct
around how you say all this like no no
no we're all different in our own
special way but like I see you as the
sexier modern more fun version that I
would want to be a part of is that not
like it or is it is it much different my
whole career my like 15-year internet
career it's been based on like taking
old ideas and just putting new spins on
it and so like that's what we did with
newsletters newsletters have been around
before the internet and we just put a
different spin on it and people are like
oh you created this amazing interesting
new thing I'm like no not really it's
not that new it just we just like you
know put a different logo on it and we
had our texture we added our texture to
it and we did the same thing with this
one but like
I if I make fun of these other companies
I'm only joking because they serve a
need but like there's YPO so YPO has
been around since the 50s it's a really
big business but YPO it's like 50 and 60
year old men and we make a joke at
Hampton where we're like
not a lot of people in our group their
businesses aren't inheriting 15
apartment buildings in South Florida uh
YPO exists for that and YPO does have
like a lot of like tech people and
internet people but it is a little the
age range is much older it is a little
bit more boys club YPO without Cialis
[Laughter]
yeah I can say these things because it's
not my business
and they're cool and all but they're
just they're just older and so
uh Hampton it's it's digital first uh so
like we have d2c companies who aren't
tech companies and we're like should we
call it tech companies and like they're
technically not tech companies but
they're tech companies if you call if
you tell your mom what you do so they're
like tech companies internet companies
that's where they are a lot of people
who you recognize on Twitter are members
so that type of stick
um uh a lot of like just consumer
software companies a lot of B2B software
companies but almost everyone's software
or internet based
um and it's significantly younger than a
lot of uh of these older companies and
then compare it to like a mastermind
which I don't even use that word those
are typically like 50 a lot of them can
be like 50 Grand and it's a little bit
more internet marketing so this is very
much like a startup so let's do the
internet I think the best sales pitch
like with any Community is who else who
am I doing bad no no you're doing good I
just want to make sure I get you to the
good bits right I'm I'm your wingman
here I'm trying to get you laid here so
here let me let me help you out
it says on your website your website's
nice by the way I want to talk about one
thing in a second here which is that you
did this differently than your other
stuff you like hired a fancy design
agency and you like picked a good name
you like built it in stealth you like
violated a bunch of your own rules which
I think is kind of awesome I want to
hear about those in a second but first
uh it says the average Hampton member
has 23 million in annual revenue and
then there's some minimum
um and
like any Community the most valuable
thing is who else is here because that's
what I would care about right like okay
you uh I like the idea I always like the
idea it's like any I like the idea of a
party but who's coming and so who are
give me like I don't know three four
five however many you want like give me
some stories of interesting members
you've met
um that have made this like fun for you
to come under Community for even you to
be a part of I'm gonna give you two
categories one the people who you know
and then two the people you don't know
the people you do know covers everybody
pop that covers 100 of the pie chart
dude so
like uh pomp Anthony who was on the Pod
a few weeks ago he's a member so pomp
has a media company and an investment
company and you guys have if you listen
to the party you know who he is Patrick
Campbell bootstrapped his company profit
well to like a 200 million dollar exit
your friends uh bump Health you know
bump health of course they make uh yeah
they well you know uh what's the same um
Leland uh his wife Christine's a member
uh they they bootstrap their company to
tens of millions in revenue and they
create uh it's a prescription for
pregnant women yeah
yeah uh CB insights Anon from CB
insights one of the most impressive
people I've ever gotten to hang out with
very level-headed and but like just
quietly building you know uh CD insights
I have you heard that Lil Wayne Uh quote
where he's like real G is moving silence
like lasagna that's that that's a non
um Austin Reef he's in my group so my
former enemy now one of my closest
friends Austin Reef from morning Brew is
a member Nick Huber sahil sieva all
these types of people but let me tell
you about the people who you probably
don't know
have I ever told you about Brett Adcock
uh if you've mentioned this guy because
he took some flying car company public
or something like that but tell the
story all right listen to this so this
guy named Brett Adcock he started this
thing called veteri which was a
Marketplace for talent but it was very
much like hired so if you're an engineer
you go through all these tests they kind
of like algorithmically and kind of
manually match you with cool interviews
they eventually bought hired he sold it
for 100 million dollars he took a bunch
of his earnings from that and he started
Archer which he took public at the time
for like 2 billion market cap now is
like six or seven hundred million but it
was a flying car company basically they
kind of look like helicopters but
they're like unmanned uh flying things
that United Airlines bought a bunch of
and he took time off between veteri and
Archer to study how it worked he
literally went to like University of
Florida to like learn how this works now
his latest company which I'm a personal
investor of is called a figure and I
went to his Factory and he's like and
they basically are these robots that
look like Robocop and instead of killing
you though they just uh you know load
t-shirts into packages for Walmart
Walmart's a hypothetical one and they
ship ship it off so you know there's
like millions of people who are doing
this who are getting paid yeah what do
you call it yeah Pick and Pack there's
20 000 of these three PLS in in America
did you know that I didn't know there's
twenty thousand yeah
we ran one right so I hired a bunch of
people to do this I've done a lot of
Pick and Pack myself because people call
in sick to work it's crazy so he's built
these robots that could basically run
they call them humanoids and he's like
they can run for 20 hours a day they
charge for four hours a day and they're
just packing stuff and it's all using
robots but he took like 20 or 30 million
dollars of his own money and he was like
I basically own two stocks or one stock
Archer my publicly my public company and
then all the cash that I have I bought a
house and then I put invested all of it
into figure my new company this guy's
like all in on it it's pretty wild
another interesting person we talked
about Anya of rooted she's the one
person meditation app it's a panic
attack app that does over a million in
Revenue so it goes all the way from
folks like Brett who are on their ways
to be billionaires all the way down to
Anya who's got a million dollar thing
that she's slow growing slowly but she
owns 100 of it another interesting one
AJ Patel another guy who's pretty under
the radar
pause guy yeah he bootstrapped zesty
Paws to a 600 million dollar exit now he
has a new thing called high key we
talked about him a lot he's he's pretty
baller and so how does it work these
people you get put in a group of peers
uh so you get you apply you get accepted
you get matched into a group and then
you meet once a month with a facilitator
who guides that discussion right yeah
and the meetings have these like uh like
we've like like we review each meeting
afterwards and we like study what's the
good what's the bad and then we've just
shaped the um the format so what makes a
great meeting versus uh just okay
meeting so what I learned from the
podcast is basically these meetings are
basically content so I try to find juicy
good content so a really good meeting we
do this thing called the business
breakdown well someone will like do a
SWOT analysis strengths weaknesses
opportunities
um what's the other T threats uh on
their on their business and they'll
explain how it works what their CAC is
where they're getting customers and they
just reveal everything and they're like
here's where we suck here's what we rock
what do you think I should do and here's
the issue that I'm facing and so that's
a really good meeting when they do that
so triple whale you one of your uh best
investments of all time he's uh he's a
member and they'll just explain how the
companies works and they're like on on
paper and this is no threats for Triple
A yeah this what I must say is not from
for Max is for everyone uh what they'll
say is like it's going well but like
we're sucking here here and here or
we're about to lay people off or uh we
just got an acquisition offer and it's
way below our valuation whatever uh and
so they like will Ex and so people will
have all types of contacts on their
companies to in order to give advice so
that's a good meeting and then we've
hired how many do we have we probably
have 30 or 40 facilitators on staff
right dude and that's hard wrangling
these people up is hard and like
training them so it's been like a that's
been the biggest challenge and that's
our biggest cost is is trying to figure
out how to get these people to do stuff
well now let's talk about how you
decided to start this so again I think
if I had said what is the Sam par
startup method I would have said um
the first bit I think was was kind of
correct which was sniff around for the
opportunity I think you are a
world-class
you know Hound sniffer yeah top five
sniffer I know
easily
uh so you're good at finding opportunity
and that what that means is you talk to
a bunch of people and you bluntly ask
them be like is that a good business and
then they're like well yeah I mean we
did this much in Revenue you're like oh
I was just asking but thanks for telling
me
you do a good job of basically finding
interesting models or you know that or
businesses that you think are good
businesses so at that part I think was
straight out of a straight out of your
normal Playbook and so you did a good
job with that
then you were like
okay I could see this business and I
think you even like talked to somebody
who had bought a company like this like
private equity and you were like yeah
why'd you buy I don't call them how do
they grow well year by year what's your
plan with them
um would you buy another was this like a
one-off outlier or are there other
businesses like this and you're you
basically Got Confidence so those some
of your method uh dude I called the guy
and I was like look
hey uh I just got I found your number on
the internet I I don't want to sound
like a douchebag here but here's who I
am so I'm kind of like legit and I'm
gonna create something that I have a
feeling you're gonna want to buy I don't
know if I'm ever gonna sell it but I
have a feeling you're gonna want to so
it's it it makes sense for you to have
it talk with me right now and I have a
particular set of skills
well thankfully taken speech
very humbly I was trying to be very
humble but yeah and he like told me a
little bit about the business he didn't
reveal anything that I I mean I could
have found a lot of it online uh but he
didn't it's not like broken the like
confidentiality stuff but yeah I did
that and then I just created a type form
and I created a Google doc I just wrote
out in one page what my new idea is who
should join who shouldn't join and at
the bottom was a type form and I sent
that Google doc to like 50 friends and
like 20 of them signed up and I
interviewed all of them so I actually
took a screenshot look at my calendar
you see my calendar down here no my
calendar it's like a zebra there's like
Stripes basically I did like it
weird flex but all right
got that zebra calendar I got that zebra
counter basically and like there's no
meetings of the day that you'll see
there's no meetings on the day we record
the the Pod but besides that there's
like 10 to 15 meetings every single
non-mfm day yeah and I would just bought
you one of those Bluetooth headsets like
you were a telemarketer because I was
like I think Sam is just doing these
like 20 minute calls all day like for a
while you were doing that right you were
doing basically only 30 minute sales
call or Discovery call
um every day all day because we used to
be completely unscheduled right like we
had that elephant schedule it was just
clear gray nothing there and I could
call you anytime we could have a little
chit chat it was fine and then all of a
sudden you started this business and you
became the machine was it hard to became
the machine was it hard to flip the
switch or in a way I here's my suspicion
in a way you kind of missed that and it
felt fun to go like super like hardcore
about it it was awesome but it was hard
it was like lifting weights like during
it like I was proud to do it and I was
happy to do it but it was very
challenging and so I was like doing all
these calls and I would interview people
figure out who is interesting who's not
interesting who we should turn away who
we should accept and then we just sent a
stripe link and we accepted payment and
then we said all right you have a 30-day
delay we went out and found the
executive coaches the facilitators we
trained them and then the first meeting
started and we did that for about a
hundred people without any website and
we didn't create a website until around
December and when we created a website
correct mindset no yeah many seven
figures in Revenue uh uh
the way you're talking about money is so
funny many many centimeters
humans don't talk like this
millions millions in run rate it was
like we were doing good I was doing good
it was just me and Joe so basically he
would go out and find the facilitators
and I would go out and like find the uh
by the way there's a great story here
because if you actually go to the
website ceomastermind.com
same business idea that you're doing
right now was a business I started at
the very beginning of the podcast very
Loosely I uh I was like hey this
Mastermind thing is really great uh it's
helped me a lot in my life anybody want
to join one and create one here put your
thing in and I think I did uh 250 or 300
per month per person so it was like
three different I thought that was Club
LTV which was like the greatest name
ever separate that was separate first
was CEO Mastermind I think I still have
the website CEO it just says index I
think yeah maybe I didn't renew or
something like that but
um
uh yeah something like that basically I
had created this website this is how I
met Ben by the way Ben was the one of
the six people that signed up for this
in the first batch I said oh I'm only
having one group and I made this thing
on click funnels and
um they joined the group and I was the
facilitator uh which was a you know bad
move a bad move because why did I quit
because I was like I don't really want
to be facilitating this anymore so I'm
not gonna do this business and the
obvious it's the same mistake I actually
made in my sushi restaurant which was
the restaurant was actually quite
profitable from month one but I hated
going every day at five in the morning
to the fish market picking up tuna and
then making the spicy tuna makes the
hated all the stuff and any smart person
would have just been like you need to
hire somebody to do that and um in my
head it was just like if we hate doing
this everyone's gonna hate doing this
this is terrible I don't want to do this
anymore I'll get me out of here and
similarly for the CEO Mastermind I think
I was the facilitator which was a bad
move because really what ended up
happening was I couldn't resist solving
everyone's problems and everybody who
joined was a fan of the Pod so they
really just want to talk to me they
didn't really care about their peers and
so uh that was a mistake on my part but
I'll tell you something Ben came out of
that so I got my win out of that which
was I met Ben he became my business
partner the second thing was it is a
great lesson in turning the intensity
knob up it's like for anyone out there
who's like oh I had that idea no no I
literally had this idea I was in the
same position as Sam had this idea
before Sam created the website created
the Prototype did the first round of it
for a few months and then decided I
don't really care about this six grand a
month right now I don't really wanna I
don't know if I want to grow this I
don't know how I don't know how and I
just sort of let it die on the vine
fast forward three years Sam tells me he
sends me that Google doc if I want to
start this business I'm like oh that
sounds super familiar I know that idea
that's that's interesting I actually you
know what I always did think that was a
good idea but and so and then I got to
see I got to watch it's like watching
your buddy date your ex it's like I got
to watch Sam send me a chart every day
of the AR going up like just exploding
like oh dude we're gonna need bigger
paper eight by elevens not cutting it
the bar charts going off the page and I
was like this is a great example of when
you turn the intensity knob up to 12.
because you were willing to do the sales
calls every single day every day every
30 minutes all day uh you were
immediately going out and hiring people
so that this could scale you wouldn't
have to get bogged down in the
operations you could stay focused on
growing it you did all the things that
anybody would anybody smart would advise
somebody to do you were doing all those
things and it was great to see and I say
this not to say uh that you that you
winklevossed me or anything like that
that's not what that's my takeaway but I
say it as a joke because I really that
is my takeaway which is the difference
between success and failure is often
just turning the intensity knob up now
at that time I just sold my company I
was still working at twitch I I don't
think I really would have gone and done
that I don't think I really even wanted
to do that but man is it a powerful way
to see like a an A B test here's
somebody who does it as a one of the 10
things that they're doing in a light
intensity and it's really fully
committed and versus somebody who's
fully committed who turns the intensity
knob up to 12. same idea using the same
uh you know fundamental platform of this
podcast as like you know your your
launch pad for that where I don't know
maybe not the launch pad because you
need to promote it on here but you know
the credibility you had when you hit up
those people like a lot of those people
you mentioned were from dude I think
this uh this business would not be good
for you in fact I don't think this
business is good for me to run so I've
hired I we got it to a certain size and
then once we could we hired a CEO and
that's within less than a year right
which is yeah unusual but I think
probably
that you had a reason you wanted to do
that or you actually probably planned to
do that from the beginning why is that
uh no I we didn't plan to do we we or we
didn't plan to hire this person uh we
hired Jordan but did you did you think
you would be the CEO or did you know
once it once it started working I was
like oh man this is going to be
significantly bigger than I think it can
be and also I don't have the skill set
it's a very operational heavy thing and
you have to be very calm and patient and
talk to people like really politely
constantly and it's a very people-heavy
business so you know we have dozens of
these facilitators and like wrangling
them up and like figuring all that out
figuring all that out it's quite hard
and I don't have that ability and I
don't have the ability to run a really
big company which I think this is going
to be so no we I don't think you could
have done this I I know for a fact I
could have done this or could not have
done this and you would have had to hire
someone as well hiring a CEO this early
is hard it's hard to hand over your baby
so I think people I know when Andrew
comes on people always ask oh ask them
about hiring a CEO I don't know why I
think it's another one of these easy
buttons people want to push of like
again it's like the mentor thing oh this
person will solve all my problems oh if
only I found a great operator then I
could have all of the ownership and none
of the work this sounds fantastic and of
course that does happen it's not that it
doesn't happen but I think a
disproportionate where people are
interested in that uh do you have
anything interesting you could say about
finding and hiring to see on how you
know that they're the right person for
for this business and taking that big
leap of faith of handing a working but
early business to somebody else
so when I write like three months before
I was selling the hustle uh about like
literally three weeks before I started
uh selling it before I got the email
from HubSpot I started talking to this
guy named Jordan who is the chief growth
officer at uh Motley Fool which is you
know like at the time like a 500 million
dollar a year thing and I was like
Jordan I want to hire a CEO for the
hustle uh and I started recruiting him
went to his house whined and dined him
and he was like I'm in and then I got
this call from HubSpot and I signed an
NDA and they're publicly traded so I
couldn't tell him and then about a week
before the deal closed I was like Jordan
I've gotta back out of our deal you like
I I have to take this offer and he was
like I understand
but you know I told them HubSpot still
needs someone to run the organization
within do you want it and so he said
yeah and so he ran it and so now I think
HubSpot media which is what the hustle's
called it has like 100 people and he's
done a good job then a year and a half
later two years later
he quit and uh and he was like Hey do
you wanna I heard you're working on this
new thing can I consult with you and I
was like yeah yeah that'd be great and I
was like talking to him and he was like
do you need a CEO and immediately I said
yeah but I had this weird conflict with
HubSpot and so I just hollered at
HubSpot and I explained the situation I
go man he bailed already he wants to
work with me are you guys okay with it
and so they said yes and so we
immediately got in a room and we just
hashed out a deal where he's highly
incentivized to grow the company and he
uh uh was is perfect for this because I
I think I've known like what he's about
but it was like a I guess technically a
two and a half year process and the
takeaway from this is I've I've been
recruiting this guy for two and a half
years now to like come and work with me
and so it took a long ass time and so
when we started the comedy honestly that
sounds sounds like oh that's unusual no
it's not unusual often the best people
are people that you kind of have this
like almost oh maybe the timing's not
right yet and uh and eventually in a
weird way things do fall together later
much later but those relationships get
built over time and they see you get to
see them operate over time they get to
see you operate over time and it builds
a lot of trust so it's pretty common I
think it's a good
a reminder not to burn Bridges and not
to close doors well that's what I was
gonna say you have to keep people you
got to treat people right so when we
sold the hustle I gave him like a thank
you check like you didn't work here but
I feel really bad I just want to give
you this as a token of my appreciation
he's like and like it literally a check
that just says thank you Sam
when I say big check I mean it was
physically a large check that I handed
over to him and I shook his hand in
front of it
and uh but dude you gotta treat people
right like you know uh Steph's miss
another person who I've worked with for
years she went and worked at Andresen
Horowitz and when I was starting this I
was like just so you know this thing's
available but anyway this is a long game
and you know you talked to James Currier
James currier's partner is someone who
he met James carriers is like I don't
know close to billionaire guy who has a
incubator and a bunch of other companies
he is partners with someone I believe
who he's known for like 20 or 30 years
but you have to like it's a really long
game to recruit these people yeah and by
the way Stan who's his partner
uh they've been they did businesses
together for like 15 20 years stands
currently not at nfx which is where
where James is the thing that they I
think I think they co-founded together
maybe they didn't co-founders together
but they were you know they've been
doing business together for 20 years
naturally he would have been doing that
but he got recruited by Mark Zuckerberg
and Zuck had been recruiting him for 10
plus years and finally got Stan to agree
to go to Facebook uh after 10 years of
Recruitment and um and I think now he's
left but but he worked there for you
know three four years during during that
period and uh and I think James was like
yeah that's cool like
go ahead go for it go on tour have that
experience that's great uh like you know
our partnership is still intact even if
you go do that which I think is a a
pretty awesome thing you know I Had A
and A Moment Like because recently where
I
I so I'm starting a new thing I'm not
talking about it yet either uh so I'll
come out uh let's talk about that in a
minute about why neither of us talk
about stuff exactly so I uh the plan was
me and Ben are gonna do this great we've
we just built and sold the bill crowd
um that was a big win in a short amount
of time we raised our fun together in
like one month raised up raised our own
rolling fund that can deploy I don't
know between seven to ten million
dollars per year we built a course
business that's a seven figure course
business we you know we've done like
four or five things together now made
Ben and I'm like oh we have our team we
don't need anything else
but as we've talked about this new thing
I was like you know there's one person
that I would recruit to join this uh
that I would give equity in this to
because I probably wouldn't give Equity
to anybody in this uh because I'm like
I'm sure this is going to work I think
this is going to be big so I value the
equity so why would I give money to
anybody I don't need anything from
anybody I don't need Capital don't need
experience I need to donate anything
there was one person and so I hit up
this one person and I said
listen I'm doing this thing I think
you're a perfect fit for it and for that
person honestly this is a perfect fit it
wasn't even like a sales pitch where I'm
trying to convince you it's like
literally it was a perfect match like
you know the thing you really love to do
that's all we do
um you know that real that problem with
your current thing where you don't own
any path to wealth I'm offering you a
path to wealth you know you'll own
equity in this thing
um
you know you always want to feel special
literally I'm not recruiting anybody
else this is either your job or there's
no job
um and I was like you don't have to
interview this is I know you you've
known me this was something that can
work
and the person was like wow this really
does sound perfect but you know I'm
hesitant because of this one visa thing
this logistical thing and I was like and
this person called me a few weeks after
they they spoke to you and I was like oh
well all those things are solvable and
so uh anyways long story short the
person was like you know what I'm just
too nervous about that I don't want to
you know I I I'm not certain I'm not
sure I'm ready to leave blah blah blah
and in my head my reply was like
idiot
you're an idiot thanks for notifying me
about your dumb decision
yeah it's like it's like it's like what
a cute girl like uh you know like
rejects you it's like well I don't even
want you anyway right right you have
ugly ankles and so that's how I felt I
was like wow yeah
I can't believe this person didn't take
this offer
um and so anyways I like have this like
30 second reaction where I'm like oh my
God I can't believe this person didn't
make the offer doesn't make any sense to
me and then I was like you know what
life's complicated I'm sure they have a
bunch of stuff going on
um like you know it's not as easy as a
decision these are Big leaps of faith
that somebody would have to take and you
know what I thought they were great
before this I still think they're great
I think that you know this decision I
think
um
is probably the wrong decision for them
but who knows that you know the life is
long uh I bet you I bet we'll end up
working together in the future anyways
because they're they are awesome and I
think we're gonna keep doing awesome
things eventually those things will
intersect and um and so I was like okay
that was my like reaction it brought
brought up two things for me one is a
reminder to myself don't let the the in
the moment reaction be the response
right so it's like
um don't let the rejection or the
feeling of oh it didn't work out like
for example for Jordan in this case he
could have when you when you rug pulled
him on the job offer been like F this
guy
and uh when we sold the milk Road same
thing we rejected the people who we
eventually sold to First at the last
minute and then they didn't get pissed
instead they just followed up like you
know 45 days later or whatever and we're
like hey what's up I didn't hear any
news did you guys not end up selling
like we're still open if you would like
to and we went back and ended up doing a
deal and so
I've learned over time that the real the
real ballers they don't react they
respond and so don't let the in the
moment reaction take away your future
opportunities that's the first thing
um the second thing is it highlighted to
me that courage is actually
it's massively underrated and I was like
this is I was like this person is more
talented than me and in fact often when
I work with people I'm like this person
is much smarter and more talented than
me why do I get the job why do I get the
CEO job or why do I have the most Equity
It's like because I think I just have
one thing that a lot of these people
don't have which is I have a lot more
courage and guts to go for things that I
want
um that more talented people end up over
analyzing and not going for and it just
highlighted to me the importance of
having courage and having guts to chase
after something that's good even though
there's some unknowns or some risks
involved in it and not talking about
this person's specific situation but
just as a common trait of like what's
the difference between an entrepreneur
and
um and a non-entrepreneur it's not
intelligence it's not
um Charisma it's not any of those things
it's often Simply Having the guts to go
and choose to go do the thing and so um
it just highlighted that for me I'm like
man this is a person with double the
talent I have but they're gonna get half
as far because they're lacking that one
thing I hope they over time develop more
of that confidence to go for it
um and
wow it made me act go reprice how
important that is uh as an attribute
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out-of-sync spreadsheets
serve dueling databases HubSpot grow
better
so I used to do this thing called
hustlecon which was like you know we did
it five or six or seven times and we
would get founders of interesting
startups to come and explain their story
we would have 500 up to 2500 people
there you spoke at a couple of them and
I used to tell these people all right
you're speaking slots at three you have
to come at noon for the mic check
and we'll be backstage and whatever and
little did they know there was no mic
check the mics worked perfectly there is
no mic check like you don't do a mic
check so the mic check could take one
second and so you're getting them there
three hours early was a tactic yeah the
the mic check there there ain't a mic
check we're just gonna put this little
lapel mic on you're good
um but I would tell them that because I
was like sick I get I'm gonna get to
spend time with all these like
billionaire type people backstage and
the best part was I would get like six
of them backstage at a time and there
was like a time where it was like this
woman who started class passed it was
the guy who started grammarly the
founders of away you know the travel
company the Casper Founders the founder
of wework and I remember having them all
back there and I would do what I do
which is I would just like throw a
question out there I wouldn't insert my
opinion but throw out a question out
there and I would hear them talk and
people were complaining about like
there's this one person who's like I
have to fire my VP of Finance they're
horrible you know they've been working
me working with me for two years and
I've known they've been horrible but I'm
too afraid to fire them because I don't
want the confrontation and there's
another person saying like dude I've
been raising money this whole time I got
to keep raising and I don't know if I'm
ever gonna make anything from this yada
yada yada and then there was a couple
people like Max of grammarly who uh is
just like killing it but I get to like
hear what he has to say and I remember
thinking at that moment I remember
thinking
a lot of these people are 20 or 50 times
more successful than I am but they are
not 20 or 50 times smarter than me I I
think that might be the case with a
couple of them like the grammarly guy
Max but most of the people they're like
they're not you know we had the uh Tom
from um
Quest Nutrition who sold this company
for a billion dollars I remember hearing
him say like whatever he was saying I
was like I have those same thoughts the
only difference is is that you are more
courageous than me and you started your
journey a little bit earlier and you're
getting after it and I remember that
like being around that group and then
being around our group that we had it
did a few things one it normalized
success and like another example of this
is like sports like I don't think that
Brazil is necessarily or Argentina has
genetically Superior people that make
them good at soccer it's just that they
just grow up playing and they expect to
be good and they work together and it
normalizes that type of Excellence
another thing is um
um it made me realize that the people
who I admire
they're fearful they are exactly like I
am you know I heard this guy complain
about not wanting to fire someone
because he just hated the confrontation
the difference is that they do it anyway
and so meeting my heroes that way it
really uh made me realize that they
shouldn't be on a pedestal other than
the reason of like they're just they
just did the damn thing not they're not
necessarily smarter and so you and I
have had people on this pod who are
significantly more successful than both
of us and a lot of them not all of them
they're not much better or sometimes
they're even worse sometimes we've had
some amazing guests on I'm like oh it's
kind of an idiot uh like there's been
times where I'm like but they've killed
it they've pulled it off Andrew Wilkins
is another guy who I've talked about I'm
like I feel like we're almost in the
same ballpark of like patience of of IQ
of like you know maybe one person's
better or worse but his success level is
huge because he's just been doing it for
longer and he actually like tried
something that was against the grain so
anyway that's one of like the big
expectati or the big things that I
learned being part of Hampton and also
being part of our group and that's one
of the reasons why we wanted to launch
it was to like make like normalize this
type of success so if you're in Idaho so
we have this woman named Janessa who has
a company called simply eloped you'll
have uh all they do is they sell like
wedding packages basically it's a little
bit more complicated than that but
simply a lot you can check it out she's
in Idaho has like a 10 million dollar a
year business eight million dollar a
year business and she's like in my neck
of the woods like no one's doing what I
do so I think that like I'm at the peak
right now and so it's nice to be around
other people who are killing it a little
bit harder than me and now I know have
like I know what the next level is in
the next Peak but uh yeah that's one of
the big learnings I have being around
some of these successful people and we
can move on and talk about other stuff
but I'm pumped this is out another thing
that we're doing by the way we're doing
my partner wanted to try PR and TBD if
it's gonna work or not but it's
miserable dude talking to these
journalists it's horrible I hate it I
told my girl I'm never doing this again
man being around these people you never
know like what they're gonna take out of
context or like if they're gonna come
like Angry it sucks man I hate doing PR
I've never done it and I'm never gonna
do it again doing PR I feel like is like
you know those scenes where it's like
you take out a knife and they have a
knife and it's like we're sort of
approaching each other's knife we're
gonna have to get really close if we're
gonna either of us wants to do this I
hope you're not trying to do that I have
to have my knife in case you do that's
how it's a Mexican standoff baby it's an
old in fact we should we should drop the
hard J of journalists and just call them
hurdles because you know this next in
the standoff is tough it's tough to do
but I think there's I think there's a
lot of value especially for something
like what you're doing because you're
gonna have the seed community of people
who are like founder type people who
probably listen to the Pod they know you
or they know about the hustle and they
trust you to build something awesome
then you're just gonna have a bunch of
people who've got good businesses that
are like I don't listen to podcasts and
I don't know what the hustle is yeah you
know no I I don't do that but I do read
The Wall Street Journal and if the Wall
Street Journal tells me about this thing
or if uh whatever TechCrunch tells me
about this thing in my mind it's like
credible and uh and so I think or you
know you you reach out to somebody to
join they're gonna google you
what are they going to find when they
Google you I think is a is an important
like question for people to answer when
you had done this you did a really good
rant a second ago and there was like
three or four things I thought were
awesome and that what you said
um one of them reminded me of something
I watched last night so I was watching I
was going down YouTube rabbit hole and I
was listening to I watched this video
that was
compilation of Martin shkreli's greatest
advice
uh
the whole like you know like Securities
from the law you know besides that
besides that you know there's 99 good
things to say I am buying a lot of
shkreli stock because everybody
abandoned he became a penny stock
everybody's abandoned everybody just
sort of wrote this guy off and
um I'm not saying that I would give this
guy my money
but this is a very smart person who has
very interesting things to say he is
very entertaining first of all
um and secondly he's got interesting
things to say and he's he's very very
intelligent
um did he do uh something wrong did he
commit a crime it sounds like it I don't
know I didn't go look at to all of it
but he went to jail uh would I you know
trust him with everything in my life
would I give him you know the password
to my bank account hell no
but I do think that in general people
just write off people way too quickly uh
what did he say and there's a whole
bunch of interesting things so in this
compilation it's like a 30 minute
compilation and halfway through he goes
he does this one thing somebody's like
oh yeah you know something about being
successful and Martin's like
he's like you know please first of all
you don't have to want to be successful
right like you you get to choose what
you want what's success for you uh I
play this capitalist game I like success
success in this way and it's what
matters to me and he's like so so if you
want to do that he's like you know IQ
nah like IQ is not the thing he's like
there's like a minimum amount of IQ you
probably need it's not as high as you
think if you're watching this video you
probably got it and he's like uh also
bad news your IQ is not gonna change so
worrying about IQ isn't going to help
you
um he's a pretty IQ he's I think he's a
high IQ he's a high IQ kind of a guy but
he's he's like I've met a lot of people
and he goes actually the higher the IQ
tends to run into one problem which is
they just overthink everything they over
complicate everything and he's like he
basically described my favorite my meme
of the year the midwit meme which is
basically like you know the idiot the
the sort of numb skull on one side and
the Jedi on the other and then the
middle is the uh the sort of the midwit
which is the the person who's got the
high IQ but the lack of Courage and the
the lack of wisdom to know how to zoom
out
um and they over analyze and over assess
everything he was basically describing
how this happens for most people and I
thought
um man it's so true what he's saying
that like after the higher IQ he's like
he goes they just get in their own way
and I got to tell you that hit
different when he said that I was like
it's so true I know the times in my life
where I get in my I get in my own way
and like what's an example
oh tons like um
uh like I I'll give you an example
because I have somebody who's like a
mentor of mine that I text all the time
about my business stuff
and usually just the act of typing it to
this person I'm like I know what they're
gonna say because they're they're on the
Jedi side of things where they're like
like I was talking to them about
um I've given this example before my
Ecom Biz where I was like
I was like okay we got the Facebook ads
up and running
um it's working
um you know I'm thinking we should do
influencers I think influence could be
huge for us and I'm thinking um we don't
have Google but people are you know
obviously there's a lot of search
traffic look I I attached this PDF of
report of search traffic and what do you
think about SEO I feel like SEO could be
good because it's cheap and then what do
you think about and I was just like
saying all this and then my Jedi
friend was like
um don't talk about don't say the word
influencers until you're making 400 000
a month on uh on Facebook ads
and I was like oh okay he's like because
remember like we said at the beginning
Facebook's probably gonna be the biggest
driver so if you can't get Facebook ads
to work none of this other stuff's
probably gonna work and the best way to
get Facebook ads to work would be too I
was like focus on it yes
and so just having somebody who could
just Jedi zoom out and be like
don't say don't say all these words like
don't say the word influencer until you
get to this amount of money then you're
allowed to talk to him about influencer
Peter tool has the same thing he used to
do at running PayPal famously it's like
was Peter teal a good manager and people
like no like managerial skills or like
soft skills are not what Peter Thiel is
known for but he did one really
effective tactic which was everybody in
the company would have their one key
thing that they're working on their One
mission that they have and if you ever
tried to talk to him about not your
mission he would simply get up and leave
the room he would be like oh you're
talking to me about not the mission
bye
what did you say like Wilkinson is this
a balloon floating away
it's a very hot air ballist turns on the
Fire floats away bye
to us back in the distance and uh I've
taken that like philosophy I'm not as
hardcore about it as I want to be but
like that's how I feel when I talk to
people my company I'm like oh
remember that thing we wrote down that
we said was the most important critical
thing the main thing oh you're not
keeping the main thing the main thing
big problem all right great and um and
you see this all the time like the
example I gave of the smart person who
turned down the job that was perfect for
them
um they needed the Jedi to be like you
want all these things and you just got
offered all those things like take it
figure out the rest after that
um you know you know that's that's the
Jedi zoom out and so similarly I think
that being in these types of groups
helps you with the Jedi zoom out because
you will you will get out of your own
way about some part of your your brain
that's Tangled Up in a knot where you
are overthinking over analyzing over
complicating something it'll happen with
like you know yeah I heard this guide
it's just not working out but I feel
like maybe I haven't put in the right
position and then the peer group will be
like
so you're saying that they're lazy they
misrepresented what they did before and
you've tried to give them the freedom to
do something and they're just not doing
you know
sounds like it's not working out maybe
you should let them go
and then yeah you get obvious well I'm
just thinking I'm gonna do this they're
like do you think that in the six months
it's gonna improve no I just there's no
way
so then do you think you should do this
plan right it's like it's the just
obvious it's the common sense but common
sense is fairly uncommon
and this is the first time I've launched
something significant with an audience
and I remember talking to you with the
milk Road I think you launched it
January a year ago yeah
end of December January yeah first
edition came out and
you like were so excited and with this
pod we don't hold back and so you're
just like telling me how excited you
were but it was live and then it was
working and everything but I remember
you like forwarding emails or just
talking to me you're like well here's
the milk Road for Brazil it's live
already they're just like they send it
10 minutes later but they just copy and
paste it and I actually met one of these
guys the other day he was like yeah I
was one of the guys copying milk Road
and he said like he said the most
beautiful thing ever at least to our
ears he was like but then I only did it
for like a month or two months and I
realized it was too hard and I can't I
can't actually pull it off and I was
like awesome that's exactly what we like
to hear but I remember you like
I remember you uh were like yeah this
sucks like all these people ripping us
off and it I don't think it made any
impact on the actual business but it
does like distract you and it gets your
like cortisol levels going and it was
the same thing with us with this
audience and so there was a few times
where I would throw like little Easter
eggs out there like I would throw like a
domain name like one time I just
mentioned Marathon Ranch which was like
the URL of my Airbnb and I didn't expect
anyone to actually book it or I would
mention like these other things that I
had access to and I'd go and look at the
analytics and I would see like oh wow 10
or 20 000 people came to the website
um I'm gonna not mention this because
I've learned from Sean's stuff of like
let's not mention something until it
gets to a certain size and there's a
bunch of other reasons which is like you
don't want the community to get too big
too fast and all that but just the
pressure of like people talk about like
they build in public a lot of people who
build in public they do it as a
marketing scheme they do it to get
traffic or to get awareness you know
buffer did this buffer was one of the
first peoples I've ever seen where they
revealed all their revenue and they also
revealed all their salaries and that was
like their shtick like that's how we
know about them other than their
products great and everything but that's
how they got out there but once you and
I were in the very fortunate position of
having an audience the name of the game
for all uh for us a lot of times is just
shut the hell up don't talk about
and I remember like being in like seeing
what you're going through and I'm like
I'm not mentioning a thing anymore about
certain stuff well I think uh I think
you're right but you're focusing a lot
on the like competitive aspect of it
which I think is overblown and doesn't
that's overblown yeah I think I think
it's overblown I think it's the pressure
and the lack of flexibility which is in
the early days of something you you
don't have a lot going for you right
it's like
um it's like do I have a big brand name
no do I have a good track record of
success and a bunch of customers no do I
have a well-established product no I
just built it last week right so it's
like you don't have
where are the attributes you don't have
any of those attributes but the one
attribute you have is basically like
Speed and Agility the ability to to
change be flexible adapt and um and and
and and turn on a dime uh as you see oh
the market actually wants this and so
the reason for me to not talk about
something early on is
um
typically that Vault two things one is
with the podcast you're inviting a bunch
of guests over to the house that's I
want to clean up the house a little bit
right because they're I'm going to get a
lot of traffic from day one whereas
before I had an audience I wasn't going
to get a lot of traffic from day one
cool I'll shout it out only 10 people
are going to come to the site anyways
doesn't matter how crappy it looks with
something like this a bunch of people
come so you you kind of don't want to
put your your worst foot forward there
but the most important thing is you
don't want to go tell the world I'm
doing X it's gonna be the best thing
ever and here's exactly how it works
because you lose a little bit of that
flexibility and adaptability that's
really your only attribute when you're
when you're young right so it's like a
kid or a baby like they're hyper
flexible and they can fall down like a
kid can't sprain an ankle because
they're they're everything is just too
like malleable right they can learn
seven languages because their brain is
like so malleable a startup is kind of
the same way when it's when it's young
which is that the only Advantage it has
is that it's really valuable so don't
Harden that too quickly by going and
publicly announcing it when you may not
have you know tested it enough to
understand and exactly what you want it
to be and how you want it to work that's
my my take at least
and let me give you let me give the
audience two business ideas that I've
discovered while working on Hampton
the first have you heard of Haro it
stands for help a reporter out Haro
h-a-r-o so Haro was launched I think in
like 2005. it was pretty early and if
you're a new startup or even just like a
smallish startup and you want backlinks
it's based in so you're a user you sign
up and you're a PR or you're you're a
startup person and you're or you're a PR
person and you get an email once a day
sometimes like three times a day and on
the other side it's a journalist so
someone at Bloomberg says I'm writing an
article about the surge of uh interest
in homemade bread uh I need I have a
deadline tomorrow so I need to get on
the phone immediately and so
the recipient will receive an email of
like 10 of these types of requests and
they reply and they go oh yeah I
actually am a bread maker or I'm a
bakery and we just switched entirely to
selling home kits right uh get me on the
phone and they do that because they want
the link or they want the little bit of
press
that company was acquired by what's it
called decision
uh and it's kind of like just kind of
floating around it doesn't seem like
it's being innovated or anything like
that but I'm pretty sure they have like
one and a half million subscribers and
people pay money to access it I think
that someone can redo Haro because we've
had like reporters come to us and be
like hey can you introduce me to like a
Founder who's doing this this and this I
have a story I'm like yeah sure I we
have hundreds of them
um I think someone can build that out in
a little bit better more interesting way
and could have a pretty nice size
company really quickly so Haro but redo
it another one
I still in our community the number one
most common thing that people talk about
is does anyone know of a good blank that
can do blank so does anyone know like
Has anyone used triple whale or a
competitor what do you think has anyone
does anyone know of a good lawyer right
does anyone know of a good freelancer
who could do blank I think you can look
at just all the categories and I would
create Niche websites for each or Niche
newsletters so
um uh long form copywriters here's the
50 people that we've vetted and we like
you can pay access to view the list or
here's a bunch of graphic designers who
turn around quicker than normal they're
cheap and they're reliable this is this
list or lawyers or payroll software
whatever and I think that you can build
a pretty big business doing that because
this is the most common problem that a
lot of people are posting about in our
community is vendors it's wild I'm
shocked that it's consistently that I
have a buddy who's doing something like
this
um
Julian Shapiro and so I don't know if
this is up right now but it's called
uh while you're talking I I thought
about making just like people are always
like I need writers and I'm like I
should just create Sam's list and it
costs like 500 a month and I'll just
update it with interesting people that
were vetting right uh who are good
writers and we approve of but I think I
think you could do that so we might have
to leave this out but um it's called the
pineapple list so basically Julian was
like all right he's in the growth world
and he's been doing growth for a long
time with demand curve and a bunch of
things like that and so he's like
basically I've interviewed thousands of
Founders to figure out which agencies
they use so which growth agencies design
agencies contact agencies are good that
we use and um and he's like so all you
got to do is you come tell me what type
of agency you need what your budget is
and then we will just give you here's
the top you know one or two or three
um and we charge you no money for that
recommendation we'll even you know kind
of hop on a call and review some of
these agencies for you and the agencies
pay them for that lead this is a genius
idea I think this is going to work
really really well and
um
and yeah I I think this is a great idea
and I think it solves an important
problem which is uh you know in our
founder group chats what question gets
asked all the time hey anybody got a
blank and blank that they love or hey
anybody tried this I'm looking at it
right now and then you get the like the
real inside scoop I visit legit is it
not is it is it just okay is it great
Etc
man I think these can be big and they're
they're they're not uh they're they're
hard but they're really simple and if
you have three months of free time just
go pick a niche and go interview all the
vendors in the space as well as all the
customers in the space as many as you
can and get the truth about what they
hate and what they love and create like
a really vetted highly vetted list I
think you could make a lot of money
right doing something like this and it's
a it's just a very Crystal Clear product
Market fit type of type of solution
right
um yeah that's a good one all right do
we want to do anything else should we
wrap I think we should wrap thank you
for
putting my company describing it better
than I even could I'm nervous man I've
never been this nervous or at least I
haven't been this nervous in like four
or five years the business is already
kicking butt you already have a great
Community this business is going to work
this is there's nothing to be nervous
about at this point
um also I think uh you know I hope we
did a good job of basically not only
explaining what it is uh but like
hopefully some of the interesting things
around it so that this isn't just like a
one hour long sales pitch about Hampton
but like you know some of the thought
process that went into how did you
launch it what did you do differently
this time you know I hope there was some
good nuggets in there you can let us
know in the in Twitter if we went too
far if it was good
um and uh and the last thing I think is
you know
you've been working on this now for how
many months
since July so it's March nine months
like that
um you know that's a long time a long
build up and so I think you deserve to
have this episode to to kind of talk
through the whole the Genesis of it how
you went about it how it's going
interesting stuff that's happened along
the way you know uh that that is well
well learned well deserved and I
guarantee you I will predict and
guarantee really that this is going to
be a
greater than 100 million dollar a year
Revenue business which means it's going
to be worth something like
low end
300 400 million high-end billion dollars
um I think I think that is the case
extremely high probability in my head
um well thank you that's awesome that
makes me feel good
um
you know it's true I dude it Ebbs and
flows and so I just want everyone to
know that like I've built a six a
successful-ish company before with the
hustle you know we had tens of millions
of Revenue and it exited and all that
every single day I wake up and I'm both
one I'm like this is gonna conquer the
world and then the next hour I think
this is impossible how are we gonna get
this done so like I want everyone to
know that the emotion still there that
like it it doesn't go away you know it
doesn't matter how fit you are running a
race is painful it's a different type of
pain but it is always painful and is and
hopefully it's also rewarding but it
doesn't matter if you're lifting 100
pounds or 500 pounds going to 99 Max 99
of your max is challenging yes good news
bad news good news hey that feeling is
normal
bad news it doesn't go away
when are we gonna when are we gonna when
are you gonna launch your or announce
your thing do you know uh I don't know a
little bit of time a little bit time all
right well thanks for listening if
you're interested
joinhampton.com I'll bring it up every
once in a while on the Pod but uh yeah
just check it out we're not gonna we're
not selling it too hard or I'm not
selling it too hard the point it's like
a Harvard it's like Harvard baby so we
want to our our our metric of success is
how many people we turn down yeah
exactly so go ahead and apply just so
you can get that big fat rejection and
then we get that acceptance rate under
one percent yeah yeah we need a lot of
people apply so we have more people to
turn down I'm kidding thank you for
checking out
joinhampton.com thank you everyone
that's it
[Music]